[Música]
este año voy a cumplir 60 años de edad
sin duda la humanidad nunca había
cambiado tanto en estos 60 años como
cambio en 5000 años una de las
industrias que más ha cambiado en esta
época ha sido la industria del cine
recuerdo que en 1961 disney lanzó la
premier 101 dálmatas esa película
obviamente después de ese lanzamiento en
esa época años después llegó a colombia
recuerdo después que en los años 90 ya
salieron las videocaseteras y nosotros
podríamos disfrutar en nuestros hogares
las películas que se iban lanzando en el
mercado en 1994 fue el lanzamiento del
rey león' recuerdo muchas veces que en
mi casa con mis hijos vimos la película
del rey león y hoy mis hijos aún
recuerdan los diálogos de tantas veces
que vimos el rey león en los ya
finalizando los años 90 salieron los
divides que sin duda mejoraron la
calidad y la oportunidad de las
películas que podíamos disfrutar en casa
ya en esta época
disney con el stream y que está
ofreciendo ya podemos tener unos
lanzamientos a nivel mundial en uno de
los personajes de 1961 cruella
disney lanzó la premiere este año y la
pudimos disfrutar en nuestros hogares de
manera inmediata en una primera premiere
a nivel mundial esto lo podemos
disfrutar hoy en nuestros celulares en
nuestros computadores en el hogar o en
cualquier lugar del mundo de manera
instantánea pasamos entonces de tener
unas películas que demoraban años en
verlas a tenerlas de manera inmediata
sin duda una transformación muy
importante en la industria del cine
mi padre fue compositor colombiano
compuso más de 60 canciones por esa
razón siempre en mi casa hubo música
siempre es de que tengo uso de razón
recuerdo los long plate que en esa época
salían al mercado recuerdo también me
tocó la época de los discos de 78 de 33
revoluciones que realmente se verá
fascinante en esa época escuchar música
con la comodidad del hogar luego cuando
yo estaba terminando ya el colegio
salieron los casettes y uno podía grabar
su colección de música en los cassettes
y reproducirlos en los paseos y
disfrutar de la música en cualquier
lugar
años después salieron los shyris y
salieron la música mp3 en los años 90
donde ya podíamos tener grandes
colecciones de música y disfrutarlos en
los discman y en los aparatos de
reproducción de mp3 a mis hijos ya en
los años 2000 les empezó a tocar ya el
ipod con gran cantidad de músicas y
listas de reproducción importantes y
obviamente ya alrededor de los años 2010
ya empezaron las las compañías de
streaming a ofrecer servicios de música
instantáneas donde ya tenemos acceso a
millones de canciones y de música
alrededor del mundo y disfrutarlas en
cualquier lugar con la comodidad de
nuestros celulares sin duda una
transformación también muy importante
que ha vivido la industria musical y que
hoy disfrutamos de manera instantánea
también en cualquier lugar del mundo
cualquier lanzamiento que se haga de los
artistas que más nos gustan
sin duda estos son dos grandes ejemplos
de lo que ha sufrido la transformación
de dos industrias muy importantes que
están en la cotidianidad de todos
nosotros sin duda también yo trabajo en
una entidad financiera donde hemos hecho
una gran transformación digital en estos
últimos años nosotros comenzamos hace
unos cinco años
a transformar todos los servicios de
información y todos estos canales de
distribución en el banco y comenzamos
inicialmente internalizando nuestro
talento nosotros creemos firmemente que
el talento es un activo importantísimo
para el banco el banco por algunas
decisiones en el pasado teníamos
externalizadas todas las labores de
soporte y mantenimiento de tecnología
nosotros decidimos que ese talento
debería estar al interior del banco hace
4 años teníamos el 71 por ciento de
nuestro equipo de trabajo era externo y
hoy ya contamos casi mitad y mitad
personas internas y de nuestros partners
de trabajo hemos decidido que la mayoría
de nuestro talento sea talento interno
pero sin duda contamos con una gran
cantidad de partners que nos proveen
recursos con conocimiento y capacidad
que apoyan a nuestros equipos de trabajo
a desarrollar la transformación digital
del banco es un trabajo conjunto del
equipo interno de nuestros proveedores
para ofrecer mejor servicio a nuestros
clientes esa fue la primera decisión
otro tema muy importante para la
transformación del banco fue empezar a
trabajar con metodologías ágiles
nosotros comenzamos hace cinco años y ya
tenemos alrededor de 310 células de
trabajo donde trabajamos con el ágil
ismo y permanentemente estamos
evolucionando su madurez para
complementar el trabajo de ágil ismo lo
que también hemos hecho en estos años es
implementar metodologías que nos ayudan
a automatizar todo el proceso de
desarrollo desde la construcción del
software la automatización de las
pruebas y automatizar los cambios a
producción
todo eso lo hacemos con tratamientos
herramientas de mercado que se llaman
desktops que nos garantizan calidad
oportunidad y seguridad para desarrollar
código seguro después de avanzar con el
divo pge encontramos que la tecnología
la nube es un habilitador de primera
orden para el desarrollo tecnológico del
banco el mundo de innovación
se mueve básicamente en el clavo vemos
que todas las startups más en el cloud y
el banco obviamente no podría quedarse
afuera de estas tecnologías
comenzamos entonces hace unos tres años
nuestro viaje al cloud y para eso nos
hemos venido preparando de manera
organizada lo primero que hicimos fue
obviamente conformar un equipo de
trabajo que defendiera todas las
herramientas y las fundaciones que
nosotros necesitamos para desarrollar
rápidamente un programa de clave y
adopción de estas tecnologías para eso
hicimos conformamos básicamente dos
estrategias todo lo que vamos a diseñar
a partir de hace tres años nace primero
en el cloud o sea definimos cloud first
como parte de nuestra primera estrategia
y segundo una migración completa de
nuestras aplicaciones a la nube en este
momento entonces estamos avanzando en
los dos planes programas que nacen
ciento por ciento cloud y migración que
estamos desarrollando nuestro plan sin
duda es bien agresivo
que en tres años nosotros podamos tener
todas nuestras aplicaciones con
tecnologías cloud esto ha sido muy
importante para el banco porque nos ha
dado no solamente velocidad calidad sino
mejorando la disponibilidad y un ahorro
de costos bastante importantes nosotros
estimamos que las primeras de cambio
hemos tenido unos ahorros alrededor del
30 por ciento y cuando terminemos
nuestra migración aspiramos estar al
100% entonces estamos muy comprometidos
con el cloud y seguimos trabajando en
esto en los próximos años otro tema muy
importante para nosotros y la evolución
de todas estas tecnologías que hemos
incluido en el banco es crear el
concepto de full stack full stack son
equipos de trabajos dedicados que tienen
todas las personas de tecnología que se
requieren para desarrollar los productos
al igual que todas las personas de
negocio que nosotros requerimos para que
hagan su trabajo y desarrollen y hagan
la evolución de los productos
financieros del banco ese concepto de
full stack básicamente una de las cosas
importantes que perseguimos con esos
equipos es que tengan autonomía y
herramientas para que ellos mismos se
provean de todo lo que necesitan y sean
capaces de manera única desarrollar los
productos para el banco todo esto sin
duda nos ha permitido en el banco
avanzar en esta transformación digital y
ofrecer mejores servicios a nuestros
clientes y sin duda poder competir en
este mercado financiero que cada vez
tenemos más competencias de las startups
de las big tex y en realidad de toda la
comunidad de innovación del mundo cuando
nosotros vemos en el mercado
experiencias y transformaciones tan
grandes como netflix y como spotify uno
dice bueno porque las otras empresas no
hacemos eso y realmente lo que hicimos
en el banco fue tomar la decisión de
transformarnos en tecnología para
realmente prestarle mejores servicios a
nuestros clientes tal cual lo hicieron
netflix y spotify creo que con todas
estas actividades que estamos
planificando y realizando en el banco
podemos también competir y ser los
spotify y netflix
de la banca hoy en el mercado vemos
excelentes transformaciones digitales en
todos los sectores de la economía
lo importante es arriesgarse para
transformar en el banco estamos en ese
camino de arriesgarnos para transformar
la forma de prestar servicios
financieros y no financieros a nuestros
clientes
[Aplausos]
[Música]